good afternoon everybody
so my name is Martin bellows I'm here
together with Johan value.now ski and
I'm gonna talk about modern data science
with facts a new approach to data frames
and pipelines so let's introduce the
team behind the effects i/o so I'm
Martin bellows former astrophysicists
freelancer consultant working mainly on
tooling and data science Jupiter core
quadruped a widget developer I work a
lot with one stack I am the founder of
exile and principal author effects what
I'm gonna demonstrate today and I'm here
with Joe Pantoliano ski also former is
the physicist and senior data scientist
and together with Jonathan
Alexander they're responsible for like
steering the data science direction
effects and together with Mallya we
broken front-end dashboards so I'm gonna
say what effects actually is why does it
exist what makes it unique and we're
going to leave the interest in to a live
demo and if I have time I'll show some
extra features so let me start with the
pie face landscape overview some people
so these are all Python visualization
libraries and some people say about oh
it's not an organized mess there's too
much needs to be convergence I would say
an optimistic view would be like you can
do anything in the Python ecosystem we
have so many to choose from there's
always a package that can solve your
solution and so what's the case with
data frames do we have so many data
frame libraries well not yet so the
mother of all pandas of course and on
top of that we have dusk data frame let
me start my timer yes
two minutes late and another like to
scale up pandas and another version
built on top of rayandpaul Nazish mode
in s frame battery now bought by Apple
not so well known at the moment q DF by
Nvidia has to run on a GPU pretty fast
there's also koalas that has upon us API
but it's using spark
and today we're going to talk about sex
al so and thanks to Mark Garcia work on
actually like be in the same room at
Euro Syfy so we're gonna see like how we
can work together but what I think it's
really important is like the data format
and the Apache arrow project is it's
enabling us to basically talk the same
data at least in the future it's it's
still young but I think that will happen
so what is facts it's a data frame
library like boundless it's actually the
Python library effects core that is just
the data frame library and on top of
that doors like support for hdf5 arrow
visualization a server for having remote
data frames and today we're going to
talk a lot about XML for the machine
learning integration and how you get
automatic pipelines BIP installable
Conda installable you can be specific
what packets you want to to have so why
does it exist it's really memory
efficient so we'll show some of that
today due to the expression system it
has and with this expression systems
will show you will have three pipelines
and we can also do just-in-time
compilation to optimize our expressions
using number Python and actually execute
it on the GPU and we're using hdf5 for
storage and to get about the arrow spec
we try to stay close to that column base
storage and memory mapping I'm gonna
demonstrate you you can open a 1.2
terabyte file on this laptop like in an
instant and just work with it as if it
was a normal data frame kind of the
sales page of FX's you probably don't
need a cluster yet
it can handle over a billion rows on
your laptop string processing is really
fast and that just save you time money
and energy I mean if you if you don't
need to spin up a cluster and keep it
simple that's only your win I would say
and so let me say a bit like what what
makes effects unique and why does it can
it handle such large data sets so let's
represent a data frame by a dictionary
like symbolically
and we have data here and X column and a
Y column
- bit small and you have a state and if
I now say DF - is DF DF y is smaller
than 10 so I filter my data frame
instead of making a copy so imagine this
was a hundred gigabyte date data set it
would like create like maybe a 90
gigabyte copy so that wouldn't work so
instead what effects does it creates it
references the same data the data is
immutable and it will keep in the state
what this filter was if you add a new
column X plus y times 10 in the state it
will add if what we call a virtual
column so jet is basically the
expression and if you want to do
computations it will do this computation
on the fly and not take any memory so
this is true but if we're gonna do it
this is my lucky slide and after this
all presentations all the mouse work so
it's this large enough no is this better
yeah so we did some imports let's see is
this still readable
no so we not on the back so it's a bit
garbled because it's so zoomed in so we
have a fell 1.2 terabyte gaya
so I told you 1.2 terabyte you can open
it so maybe that went too fast shall I
do it again basically what it does it
memory maps the data so it doesn't have
to do much and if I print out the data
frame it will just read a few bytes for
the first few rows and all the other
columns so maybe for fun I should just
do it again because I can but we're
gonna work with this data set one
hundred eight gigabytes New York taxi
data set 2009 2015 so several years of
data by the way this was 1.7 billion
rows and this New York taxi
dataset is 1.1 billion rows so let's see
what what's in there
we have pickup daytime trip distance
pickup longitude and latitude drop-off
etc so we're going to split this into a
train and test data set because later on
Yavin is going to be some machine
learning so we split it in just a small
data frame on that 50 million rows and
one of 1 billion so we're going to first
run the stripe on it just to get an idea
of the what's in the data but that takes
a while to run I mean it's a hundred
gigabytes still needs to read in the
data and I hear a fan spinning so it's
doing some work but we're not gonna wait
so let's do something in parallel why
not open the data set again because it's
memory mapped it doesn't really matter
if I open it once twice etcetera it's
all referring to the same memory so I'm
going to New York and I want to know
like what's in good tip amount so let's
take a look at what the average tip
percentage so tip amount over total
amount I'm gonna execute tip amount so
we say 13% 16% so what this is is not as
series this is an expression so it's not
taking any memory and and we want to do
computations with it so we're gonna do
tip centage so we're gonna add a virtual
column so now we added a new column to
this data frame tip percentage and it's
not taking up any any memory so let's do
some computation with it so what should
I tip so I should tip an infinite amount
okay that that's not that's not good we
had some deficients by zero as you can
see so we're now gonna filter the data
frame and this is 100 gigabytes of data
then I'm gonna filter and make a copy
FEX doesn't do this copy so this
actually runs in finite time and you'll
get an answer seven percent okay so
defense are off so probably run
described so now gonna hand it over to
yo hi everyone so we're preparing the
demo and we really thought the best way
to show the X to you is to basically
show you how it works in practice in a
live session like this so let's just
jump into it so as Martin introduced
this tax the data set I'm gonna well I'm
kind of worried that the data field will
saturate so I want to have a back-up
plan so let's analyze this just in case
something happens to the economy or
something so we have this data set we're
not very familiar so let's do some EDA
first I start off by looking well for
missing values we want to get rid of
that that's never nice so this n/a it's
kind of like pandas you see okay at the
moment everything is fine then we have
these two columns lots of missing values
will maybe see later what's going to
happen we have in the pick up latitude
one and in the drop off location we have
a bunch of them and so on
some tags people don't report it's not
surprising and so on so I'm a taxi
driver I really care about the pickup
location and drop-off location so let's
take care of that it's kind of zoom in
I'm just listing the columns that I want
a job I will execute that it runs to
profess because nothing really happens
I'm just telling the VEX state Oh
when this eventually gets executed I
want these columns denounced in these
columns to be dropped here I want to
explore the data frame more and I see
that the maximum number of passengers is
over 200 that seems kind of weird
so I want to investigate it a little bit
and I also the trip distance I see the
min/max values well one is negative the
mean value and the maximum is very large
so I want to also take care of that so
let's do value counts if you're a data
scientist V account is probably your
favorite pandas method here because we
have a billion sized rolls data set we
add at a nice progress bar so you know
how fast this goes and you may think
this is fast but actually it needs to do
some pre computation because we added a
filter
we had a train test set so if you
execute this again actually it runs even
more fast okay so we see most of the
taxi trips have a single passenger than
two five three and after around seven we
have some trips with zero passengers
that's not good and the rest is just
basically noise and just peruse data so
I'm gonna clean that to include only
passengers between well with some
passengers but less than seven now let's
look at the distance distribution I'm
gonna plot a histogram this is again
billion points in real time and here it
how it looks like big peak at zero I'm
not sure if it is really zero I'm gonna
check
I want to ignore all this negative
distances and I want to well see what
happens on this really positive tail we
really follow the pandas API here so
checking if there are any zero values is
the same as if you do in Bao in in
pandas and we see that there are seven
million trips taxi trips with distance
zero so that's not good and just for fun
I want to see what's the absolute
maximum distance that this data sent
half and it's like ridiculous number
it's basically miles have the distance
to Mars and just seventy times two to
the earth-moon distance so that's also
not good I want to get the better inside
so let's zoom in a little bit on this
distribution something it makes more
sense between let's say 0 and 20 miles
we see that it kind of tails off after
10 I only care about the bulk of the
taxi driver takes two trips so let's
filter this between zero and ten miles
but so I looked into the word this data
set comes from and this taxi company
says yeah we serve the whole of New York
is that really true so I want to
investigate this with vex with the help
of I PI budgets you can interactively
create maps like this all with basically
numbering billions of points so this is
basically New York but there are some
outliers that make this map unreadable
and I can zoom in a little bit and this
is a properly on as dam also nothing is
pre computed every time I assume in the
grid gets updated the computations are
done if this wasn't so zoom in you can
see there is another progress bar here
so I can zoom in a bit more you see the
computations boom can then and I kind of
see New York now let me zoom in a bit
more
and there it is so here I see that I
don't read it so I can't really well
I've not been to New York but this is
basically Manhattan and some airports
but you can decide of what you want to
kind of select from here so I've just
decided on some on some ranges on the
pick-up and drop-off locations again
this is just a filter nothing gets
executed I'm just updating the state so
it doesn't matter how many rolls you
have it's just instant let's create some
features we want to explore let's say
the mean tops you would mean trip speed
this is just trips being divided by by
time the by duration that's also
introduced duration and some other some
other metric that may be interested to
us okay let's investigate the
distribution of mean trips so now this
is actually a virtual column like Martin
described so when this cell executes
what it does it's actually in real time
executes about this expression in bins
it so for a billion rows this takes well
11 seconds so that's not bad we can do
this kind of in real time again we see
there is some negative durations and
then there is a big positive tail not
really reasonable let's zoom in a little
bit more yeah let's do another histogram
of a billion points in real time and so
I don't know if anybody is from New York
here I don't know how long people's pain
in a taxi but this is up to a thousand
minutes so that doesn't seem reasonable
to me well let's make a cut between well
zero minutes just a little bit more than
zero minutes and two hours if somebody
really spends that much in taxi so with
cleaning the data set a little bit
little by little
now let's look a little at fused daytime
features just like in pandas we can
extract from the pickup daytime our day
of week month we can add other features
that designate whether something is a
trip has occurred in a weekend or not
next and this is just internal Forex it
really speed things up
basically I'm ordering the both the
pickup hour and day of week and it
allows me to do plots like this I really
want to see the number of pickup
location of pickups per given day
and given time of day so this is known
as demo it really runs everything on
this laptop in real time it sometimes
may take a few seconds and this is what
a dataframe look well the result looks
like we can see this here is when we
have the most pickups kind of makes
sense and during the working days in
this in the evening we have more pickups
here here is the absolute peak Friday
night Saturday night
this Sunday spot here is really
stuttering the night just after midnight
and of course in the morning we don't
have that meaning that many trips next
if I want to be a part-time taxi driver
it I want to see okay which parts of the
day are more profitable for me and I'm
also kind of young and I want to drive
fast I want to know when I can drive the
fastest so here I can do group by the
API is exactly the same with pandas
whether it's done fully in parallel and
out of course you can use this big of
data set as you can fit in your hard
drive so this is how the resulting data
frame looks like and then you can plot
it with your favorite tools I'm using
matplotlib in Seaborn and so you can say
that this check that this makes sense
people keep the most in the morning
eight nine probably they're happy that
they made it to work on time and in the
evening well after their hippie
socializing time in terms of speed you
can drive fastest early hours in the
morning probably not my track with
traffic so here is the traffic jams
considerably slower I'm gonna skip this
nothing failed really good so now my CEO
taxi boss I can well I can investigate
the data frame again and here you can
see all the extra columns I've added the
time of day the weekend so on without
cost of any memory whatsoever so now I
want to do a little machine learning
project I want to predict the typical
duration of a taxi trip so I'm going to
import the XML which call which hosts a
bunch of modules for typical
pre-processing but this time they run
fully out of core we're kind of
following the circular convention here
here I want to show you something else
that's we think it's cool I'm gonna add
another feature this arc distance so
this is the as the crow flies between
the pick-up and drop-off locations and
just to make sense
here but this is a very complicated
expression it has a lot of trigonometry
algebra and so on so if I add it as a
virtual column and let's say I want to
do some computations with it let's say a
sum even though of X is really really
fast and parallelized and optimized and
all that it does take some maybe 20
seconds or so and this is kind of fast
already but if you happen to have a GPU
on your on your machine you can use as
Martin said CUDA to optimize your code
so I can you just do just that and
calculate this expression once again and
now it really well you get around four
times speed up compared to the to the
CPU I can choose which virtual
expression I want to use and let's say
you don't have a GPU like I have a Mac
so I can do this let's do another
complete expression but here you can use
just-in-time compilation with Moomba or
part ran to again optimize your
expression and the cool thing about this
is now when you have this computational
graph and you execute it you can use
both your GPU and the CPU at the same
time so you're really pushing your
machine to the limit to the limit and
now I can again view my data frame with
all this extra expressions that I added
at no extra memory cost all right so now
I want to do a PCA for example I want to
pre-process this dataset so I'm just
running PCA on the pick up and drop off
locations the reason behind this well I
want to show off the fast PCA but also
this is a big tabular data set and we
kind of know as data scientist that tree
boosted well tree models or gradient
boosted models work really well with
tabular data sets and the idea behind it
is that in the u.s. most cities
including New York well their streets
are kind of on a grid so New York is
kind of like this you will see now once
the plot gets gets executed if you use
PCA so you get these principal
components and your streets get a line
like this you can use this features and
your splitting of the trees will be more
effective so we can use it as a trick as
a nice pre-processing technique to get a
little bit more optimized models and
this is basically what I mean by this so
the streets are more aligned to to the
coordinates all right then I have this
payment type I can see all the
individual options that people
well the taxi drivers used to to record
how people paid and I'm also using
string processing function and I do this
in real time for a billion points and
this is all the options that the taxi
drivers used from the documentation and
no there is only a final amount of
things that you should that they should
have done so I can just simply encode
this using map just like in pandas I can
make a dictionary and map it out and
even though this is a billion points if
we're using optimizations in the
background hash functions
parallelization so this takes only a
fraction well only a few seconds ten
seconds now I can again see the data
frame and I can see all the extra
columns I've added PCA the payment type
this is just a preview now I'm kind of
happy with my with my feature
engineering I want to model this I'm
gonna select oops I'm running this again
it doesn't matter I'm choosing which
columns I want this is my target column
I'm going to import this like it sorry
legian wrapper you can use it the same
way as you're using scikit-learn and
going to Train it but I'm training it on
a small subset of the data because
psychic terrain is now by GBM is not
really out of core here now once it's
trained I can use to predict typical
predict method gives you in memory array
of the prediction however if you use
transform method on your model you can
add your prediction is a virtual column
in your main data frame and this is
quite powerful actually because now it
gives you a really easy way of doing and
sampling now you can check your
performance but this is meaningless at
into validation so let's do let's add a
second estimator because maybe Martin
think so linear models are also great
you shouldn't ignore it but linear
models require bare handing of
categorical features it's not gonna one
protein code all this categorical values
that I had and again I'm doing this for
the full 1 billion rows in real time
after this is done it's going to take
around 10 seconds or so 20 maybe because
it's a live demo I want a standard scale
this numerical features that I added so
the arc distance
Direction angle and trip distance and
here because this laptop happens to have
a GPU I'm using the
and the CPU at the same time well this
standard scaling is going on so this is
just the subtracting the mean and
dividing by the standard deviation once
this is done okay you can see that this
took only 23 seconds this is going to
take more or less the same I can just
import the cycling wrapper we're
compatible with all scikit-learn models
you can just use them out of the box
choose the features that I want to use
train again transform and once this is
done you can view data frame and now you
see all the let's say the one holding
coding columns we made there are many of
them the scaled features in the linear
prediction and one advantage here
because we're using everything so
consistently you get to keep the column
name so you always know which column
came from which transformer from which
from which process we can do now easy
assembling you can just simply average
you to prediction store maybe add
weights if you want and again this is
propagated throughout oops
fully throughout the pipeline so
actually now comes my favorite method
the power of this adding stuff is a
virtual cone is now let's say I'm happy
with this imagine that I've done proper
cross-validation and I want to try it on
the test set oh but I didn't build a
pipelines have to go back and like redo
all this actually we have been doing a
pipeline all along automatically in the
background because every operation we
did just updated the state so all we
need to do is to propagate the stray
state to a new data set it's just to
save it we can save it to disk in a JSON
and now I'm going to open another data
another notebook fully different kernel
I'm going to load up bags the same data
frame I'm going to redefine the test set
we didn't touch this we can investigate
it just a bunch of cones the ones that
are on disk I'm just going to load the
state that I just saved into memory and
now once we view this test set
we see all the troops all the columns we
defined
automatically for you done the PCA the
light GBM or the one holding coding and
all the way to the predictions at no
memory cost whatsoever well you can
check the you can check performance a
bit meaningless and now including all
the memory all the columns that we added
we see we have 88 400 million rows on
the test set on a simple laptop without
without any problems so that was the
live demo Martin we were up this up and
thanks
I think have a few more minutes just
want to mention like we're using this
there's a project that I'm doing with
the Space Telescope Science Institute
where we deploy effects on the surfer
and so you boot up a AWS machine and
then you need to wait until your copy of
1.2 terabyte fell and that's really
annoying so what we did is have
streaming s3 support so you can Rev rate
s3 file and even if I didn't have an
internet connection this is already some
of it is cached on my my disk so you
basically can work with like a data
frames from s3 boot is not notebook
anywhere and don't have to change the
path for instance I executed this before
so this already cached on my my days and
something really interesting is that
because we make this distinction between
data and state actually from many cases
we don't need the data we just care
about the state and the state only
changes at the client so in my notebook
if I add a virtual column the state got
updated updated and I can send this to a
server where the data is and that can
actually do the execution so let's see
if we have an internet connection yeah
so I can ask like remotely to give me
this plot so this is a gaya data set so
where we come from astronomy what you're
seeing here is actually 1 billion stars
from the Milky Way may be interesting to
know and you can actually do
computations on remotely on these
expressions so I think that's quite
quite an interesting side effect of of
this so I think we did well lucky slide
let me conclude so I hope I or we have
convinced you that fixes quite fast a
memory efficient data frame library and
actually we forgot to show you how much
memory Yavin was using so this is his
notebook so he was using at maximum 3.7
gigabytes of memory I think that's
pretty decent for 400 gigabytes so just
to give you an order of magnitude like
what you can
so on this laptop one billion rows one
terabyte of data that's kind of the
sweet spot for four effects we shown you
this concept of using like immutable
state immutable data and state where the
virtual column lives and the filters
giving you the option to do this on this
laptop but also to allow you to do to
optimize your expression using number
Python CUDA and you can even do like
things like derivatives and I think
what's really convincing is that this
state remembers your pipeline and it's
actually an artifact so if you have
something and you're happy with your
done you don't have to like redo a
pipeline and that makes it really easy
to for deployment and I also showed you
some s3 support and the option of having
remote data frames so if you can read it
and you cannot I guess some of the
resources and here the talks are also
online and we're probably gonna publish
some new articles the coming half a year
so if you follow us on Twitter might
embarrass or fix a oh you'll stay up to
date and now we have some time for
questions
thank you
okay cool
did you want to pick who you want to say
the custom things for the amazing talk
just one quick question
the which do you know is there any
significant part of pandas that you all
couldn't replicate yet is it like any
part of pandas that is not yet
implemented any significant part I
assume so I think there are some things
like data on pandas that that just don't
translate to this like the option to
transpose a data frame like if you would
have a billion columns that wouldn't
make sense so that definitely well I
keep saying like no it cannot be done
and then like a week later I do it but
so like a half year ago I thought that
group I wasn't possible and it is so
yeah do you know is there something
crucial mission probably there is so so
one thing that I that we don't have is
an index and and it's also like I don't
fully agree with the idea of having a
single index so I think we it mixes the
concept of having like a primary key and
an index so I'm thinking still thinking
how to like implement this by having
like multiple industries and but we are
still thinking about it
hey guys I saw some talk I would like
ask different question what are the
limitation in terms of your like
laziness and and my Mira mapped files
for example is a joint supported or is
it impossible for for bikes and like
general to do merge like pandas do so
what are the limitation of the framework
and a mindset behind the framework
another one did you consider to
contribute some of those features to
like pandas or to other ones rather than
create a new one yet another one good
questions
so the what was the about join so there
is a joint because we had to do in
astronomy we had to basically join a 1
billion row table to another 1 billion
row table and I just created like a
really simple Python implementation and
that took I don't know 10 hours or
something so it just ran it and the next
day it finished and we used actually
rewrote it in the same order it's like
in the joint order so we can also memory
map that and do basically after that I
do an instant join there's now P are
open by me that that does the join using
like C++ with the faster hash mapping
but we don't use it a lot actually but
yeah that will probably happen within
half a year and contributing back yeah
that's a difficult issue that has to do
with like funding who's doing the
funding how much free time you have I
would like love to collaborate and we're
going to talk at Euro Syfy to the other
data frame developers like what we can
do I would love to but yeah if you have
funding then let me know
hey thank you very much for a very good
talk I have a question to her support
sparse data I can I have columns which
have very few nonzero nonzero entries
like million of them shall I rephrase
yes so do you support like sparse data
so can I have like a verse my file which
contains like million columns and like
million rows but with very few entries
will it will it will your machinery
support that yes I did at a while ago
like support just to see how it would go
for sparse but a particular format like
it's like you only have a few rows that
are available and but not so many
columns but again like most of the
features that we put in are like
basically on request so we work with the
client they need this so we haven't
encountered much of this but yeah that I
think actually the better way to answer
that is to wait for PI arrow to solve
this I think they're now working on on
sparse and a lot of these questions are
actually like yeah maybe we should wait
for pi arrow to like solidify this so we
can build on top of that another
question actually very related
so you mentioned Apache our support is
that zero cost conversion do you need to
actually go through all the data and
make it compatible with the format like
all numerical types are supported and
strings strings are supported bullying's
but not yet no more complex types not
yet so but there are they from my site
there zero copy I don't know what arrow
does internally I've I've done so there
are like lots of methods in in fact to
go from panelist data frame to effects
data frame or back or to an arrow table
and deck and some of them take some
memory but I'm I didn't look into that
but it sure it doesn't like copy like I
thought like for this data set it
wouldn't use like 100 gigabytes it would
do a shallow copy
hi so this looks like a ridiculously
good tool for analysis
I was wondering how it performs in a
more sort of ETL style framework so if
you actually had to write out all of
them extra columns that you added what's
the sort of performance there yes sir
when you added all the columns as
virtual columns and then you saved it as
like a JSON blob that you could use
elsewhere what if I wanted to rewrite
the original data frame like the entire
terabyte but with extra columns I've
computed so you want to like materialize
this on disk yes yes do you have built
export is it performing what was your
question is it performant how long would
it take to write because one of the
advantages of say SPARC is that it can
write in parallel across many I would
say it's disk speed limited I think I I
don't do it a lot but I've done it like
for the Gaia data set like a lot like
making subsets and exporting them such
that you don't have to pre-compute
so actually if you want to I don't know
if this benchmark would apply for this
data set that we used because it came in
CSV format and we join them and we
export it as 100 gig 107 gigabytes on my
laptop which is a bit older than this
took maybe 30 minutes at around 30
minutes not more than 30 minutes cool
thanks
so very nice tool here's a question does
it make sense for vex to be used on
smoke I get that it's very nice for big
data set and terabytes data frames does
it make sense does it have any advantage
of smaller data friends with thousands
and hundreds of thousands of rows what
is if there is an advantage
what is the advantage or disadvantage
with pandas do you think it still makes
sense to adopt vex for smaller data sets
I don't know about all the methods but
apart from applying that we also have
index which is not parallel we have
everything else parallelized so it uses
all the course all the time if you want
to do some interface with our
pre-processing tools because everything
gets rememorize into the same data frame
you owe you'll never lose track off you
get the column names labelled for
example if you do one halt or frequency
encoding or pca everything gets smartly
labelled so this is something that I
like because when I pass through things
through let's say scikit-learn I get a
new puree and I kind of lose the label
so I have to be oh it's nice but I have
to be more careful of what's what so
that's one one advantage however maybe
we didn't mention this so we're fully in
know what I don't know what's the right
word we're fully compatible with pandas
in the sense you can import an export
data frame two pandas without a memory
copy as long as you can feel it in
memory without problems so if you if
there is something that you prefer in
one library or the other you're not
locked into one system and especially if
like if everybody starts using a patchy
arrow that then you can like change
libraries quite quite easily but I would
say like if you have heaven up to like
10 million maybe 100 million a pandas
performs great and why would you change
maybe because you want to do the
automatic pipeline step that would be
useful but I would say like above like a
hundred million it may make sense to
start taking a look at
at fix if you want to do string
transformations because we use C++ code
in the background those are
significantly faster regardless of size
okay if I may how long did it take the
implementation of the library also when
the project when did the project started
yeah so also an answer to like
contributing it's like it started five
years ago I would say but it wasn't a
data frame library but more on like
visualization for this Gaia dataset and
slowly like it it evolved towards being
a data frame library so we kind of like
used it internally and and we especially
the Johan was using pandas so it kind of
grew to that API because then I didn't
have to explain what to use and it's
just easier for people to switch and
it's it's an API that that everybody
knows so it slowly went this direction I
think starting from two years ago it was
started becoming like a real data frame
library hello do you have any native
supports for the Apache Pocky format or
should we use PI Rosa [ __ ] yeah so we
get that for free from my era okay what
is the word vex actually mean
visualization and exploration used to me
yeah but yeah it's now just a name so
I'm not allowed to change this by the
people around me they love it
any more questions apologists for an
awkward non-technical question but it's
about the open source model because you
do consulting and you also have an open
source project how do you solve this
conflict of interests for a feature
should go into a proprietary client code
or should go to open source version no
all of it is open source so there's no
proprietary code in in the whole project
but you mentioned before that a feature
depends on funding like if is a client
who needs the feature then to eventually
go into the library at some later point
if we I mean we're developing it
together and buy together I mean he does
90% of the work and I complain but if
it's some feature that we need that we
think the entire community or the
majority of the community will benefit
we'll do it if you come from a niche
field or your application is really only
applicable to you or your field then to
get priority because we're just two
people or three people that's where the
funding comes in but let me say that I
wouldn't be interested in doing work
that that for close source I I basically
wouldn't take that work that's not
interesting and I think not smart also
for the companies because who would
maintain it they would have to pay me
again so that wouldn't be smart nobody's
listening right that's all the time we
have for questions so let's give them
more run reports please
you